[MUSIC PLAYING]
So this talk is
on my first love,
which is Android development.
And this is for bringing
your existing Android
app to the big screen
with Android TV.
So let me talk to you before
I jump in for a second,
and this is for folks that are
mostly new to the platform.
So I'll give a quick intro,
then I'll talk about, basically,
the key steps in
development, and then
I'll talk about some
design principles.
So before I jump in, let
me tell you guys and girls
why I like Android TV so much.
So, I am in no way a
front end developer.
So I don't do UI
and I don't do UX.
So for me, thinking about, how
can I write a really great app
for the big screen
that's supposed
to have this great UI
with smooth transitions
and animations, right, that
people are going to look
at in groups and comment on?
So for me, I'm like,
holy crap, I'm out.
I can't do that.
But I fell in love
with Android TV
because this is actually
one of the few platforms
where I can write a really
top notch cinematic UI.
And I can do that because
Android TV, the developer
experience, is all about
providing tools, which
makes it super easy to do that.
So that's why I like
Android TV, and I'll
show you a quick preview
of how that works.
All right, so, when most
of us think about software
on the television,
we think about games.
We just saw a great talk on
Cast games, and after I finish,
we'll see a great talk
on Android TV games.
If you have an existing
game for Android,
it's super easy to
port it to the TV,
because the TLDR
of this entire talk
is that Android TV is just
Android on a new form factor.
So if you've got a game-- and
there's of course more to it
than that, but that's the
TLDR-- so if you've got a game,
you're in good shape.
But what I really care
about is apps, so just as
is true for games, if you
have an existing Android app,
the TLDR is you're also
really, really close to getting
it working on the big screen.
So this is actually "Santa
Tracker," which is super fun,
and this year it was
ported to Android TV.
So I absolutely love
just bringing stuff
to the big screen.
Something to think
about-- I'll primarily
talk about media
apps in this talk,
and that's really where the
developer tools hit home.
But you're not limited to
just building music and video
apps for the television.
You should really think
outside of the box,
like what can you do in terms
of sports or cooking or anything
that can take advantage
of the new form factor?
I think we're
actually-- going back
to this morning-- I
think we're actually
at a really special
time in the living room,
and actually as
software engineers
and developers and computer
scientists, in general.
And that's because
the developer tools
today are ridiculously good.
So back when I started
as a little kid--
like, what, I don't want to
tell you how many years ago,
but many years ago-- writing
QuickBASIC on an Apple, right?
Like an Apple II,
to think about,
like, oh man, I'm
going to sit down
and, I don't know,
a couple days later,
I'm going to have a great
cinematic big screen
app running on my TV,
would have been impossible.
That would have been like
a 15 year coding project,
and today we can do
it just trivially.
So opportunity is
the key word today.
And yeah, the TLDR is,
it is-- and no BS here--
if you are an Android
developer, it's
so easy to get it on the TV.
And I actually am very cautious
when I say the word easy.
I hear a lot of talks
where like, yeah,
it's super easy to do
this, like trust me,
use this developer platform.
But it is actually
pretty easy to do.
All right, so what's
the same and what's
different when you're going
from a mobile app to Android TV?
Starting with what's the
same, almost all of your code.
Pretty much the
main thing to do is
you need to roll a
new UI and a new UX.
And the Leanback
Library, in particular,
and the other developer tools,
makes that ridiculously easy.
Leanback is the
heart of Android TV.
It's basically a collection
of prebuilt fragments, which
we'll get into in a second.
So when folks have a TV
app, what they really
need to do is-- typically,
if you look at a media app,
there's a really common flow.
You turn on the TV and you
need to find content to watch.
There's typically two
ways you can do that.
One is you might want
to browse for it,
and Leanback provides a
great prebuilt fragment
with smooth animations
and transitions
to help you browse for content.
The other way to
find content is you
might want to search for
it, and Leanback also
provides a search fragment
with built-in voice recognition
to make it super easy to take
the user to their content
in the minimum number of steps.
After you find content, you
might want to see details on it
or take an action,
like renting a movie,
and then you want
to play it back.
And pretty much all
of the UI components
you need for this is
included out of the box.
And we actually
have a sample app
with all of this
working immediately.
And what I'll do in this talk is
look at the key chunks of code
you need to really
get these fragments
wired up, and populated
with your content.
The other thing that's
the same about Android TV
is you can actually
add support for it
in your existing APK in the same
way you do with Android Wear.
Which is fantastic
because it means
that your Play Store experience
is basically identical.
You get to use all the familiar
distribution and monetization
tools.
Super easy.
Right, Play Store.
I have like one or
two reasons why--
a question that comes up
often is, why should you
develop for Android TV?
And what I would do
is-- as a developer,
it's where do you want
to spend your time?
So it's sort of like a
risk-reward trade off.
The developer risk
is fairly low,
and I just want to show you
what some of the rewards are.
Android TV is a great way to
get your content discovered
and engaged.
Discovered means that
people need to find it.
So this is the Android TV
home screen, and the feature
that I want to point you to
is-- the central feature-- is
the recommendations row.
And what I love about this is
if you're providing-- if you're
developing-- a media
app, you can actually
publish recommendations front
and center on the Android TV
home screen.
Which means when folks
turn this thing on,
they're going to see
recommendations from your app.
And that's just a phenomenal way
to get your content out there.
Another obvious way to get your
content discovered is search.
The other central feature of
the Android TV home screen
is search, and you can
actually integrate with search.
So if I search for my favorite
TV show on the home screen,
I can actually see
results from your app.
Another reason is that, when it
comes to retaining users-- when
folks are watching content--
screen size is a huge variable.
So there's been different
internal studies on YouTube--
and this is across all
devices, not just TV,
so this also includes Cast.
But typically, if
you can imagine
that a user watches one
hour of video content,
say on their cell
phone or tablet,
that same user might be watching
in the range of 3 hours on TV.
So that's a lot of
time that you can
compete for by developing
for Android TV.
And really the opportunity
is-- when I get home--
like I've had a long
day, I'm coding,
I'm exhausted-- I spend
a lot of time relaxing,
and I think a lot of us do
in front of our TV screen.
It's a lot of time that I'm
just sitting there often--
I have a smart TV
with Android TV,
and I have some
old stuff-- using
kind of these not so great
UI's, just browsing around
for content.
And I think because the
developer tools are so strong,
you as developers,
we as developers,
really do have an opportunity
to see if we can--
I don't think
we've done it yet--
but to really come up with
what's the killer apps?
What's the next generation of
killer apps that people can
use in that three-plus hours?
I think it's actually
up to four now in the US
that we're just sitting
there on the couch.
And so this is a
huge opportunity.
For folks brand new
to the platform,
the engagement model is
a little bit different.
It's a D-pad remote control
usually, also a game
controller optionally.
There's no menu
button, no pointer.
Mostly we're navigating
systems of cards.
Everything should
be simple and quick.
And all the elements on your
UI need to be focus-able.
So what I want to
do is quickly look
at the three major steps to
getting your mobile app working
on Android TV.
And the first thing we're going
to do is update your manifest.
You don't need to
read all this, I just
wanted to drop some
code on the screen.
The basic idea here is you've
got your main activity that
launches on your mobile device.
What you're going to do
in your Android manifest
is add a second
activity, and this
is the activity that's
going to launch on the TV.
This is simple stuff, but
it's really quick and easy.
To specify the TV activity, you
would use the Leanback launcher
intent filter.
So now we've got an activity
that will launch on the TV.
Another thing you
need to do is declare
that you support Leanback.
Leanback is the UI
used by Android TV.
What's interesting
here is I've got
required false, and the
reason I'm not requiring
it is we're interested
in developing
apps that can run on multiple
different Android form factors.
So with required false, you can
also run on a mobile device.
Required true, the
Play Store is going
to say, nope, Android TV only.
Just with those
two steps you can
get your app to appear in the
apps row on the home screen.
Another difference with Android
TV is, on a mobile device
you've got an icon.
On Android TV,
you need a banner,
which is basically
just a bigger icon.
You can also specify
that in your manifest.
Something to think
about if you're
porting an app from a mobile
device is hardware differences.
So one cool thing about
mobile that I think we often
take for granted is
just the insane number
of sensors on a cell phone.
Folks are often complaining,
and I complain as well,
like, ah, the battery
life stinks on my phone.
But when you think
about how much hardware
is packed on there,
it's actually astounding
that it works as
well as it does.
So phones have gyroscopes,
accelerometers, all this jazz--
GPS, touch screens.
So when you're porting an app
to also work in Android TV,
you need to update your
manifest to specify that none
of this stuff is required.
That way it can be
installed on both devices.
Then what you want to
do is, at run time,
before you try and use
a hardware feature--
so if you're accustomed to
using the GPS-- just update
your application code to check
whether that hardware exists
on the device before
you try and use it.
Something to avoid
is-- it's also
possible to check what form
factor you're running on.
So with the UI mode
manager, I can say, hey,
am I running on a TV or a phone?
And then, access
hardware based on that.
The issue with doing this
is-- so this will work out
of the box right now.
You can say, if I'm
on a TV, I'm not
going to access GPS or a touch
screen or any stuff like that,
but I'd recommend actually
instead of using this approach,
just check for specific
pieces of hardware
before you try and access
them, and that way you'll
help future proof your app.
So if TV's down the
road have features
we don't expect them
to now, you won't have
to change your code at all.
Other gotchas is permissions.
So permissions can cause
implicit hardware requirements.
So if you have a camera
permission in your mobile app
and you port it to
the TV, that actually
creates a permission
on the camera.
So you need to watch
out for stuff like that.
Otherwise, you won't
be listed as compatible
in the Play Store.
So step one is basically
updating your manifest.
And that's mostly bookkeeping.
It's mostly bookkeeping code.
There's nothing to this, right?
And then it's just updating your
app code to check for hardware.
That's super easy.
What was personally really hard
for me before Android TV was,
how on earth am I
going to create a UI?
That's what we care about.
How can I create a good UI?
And the answer is you
use the Leanback Library.
Let's take a quick look.
So the Leanback Library,
the main feature,
is it comes with a bunch
of prebuilt fragments.
This is a static picture.
I really should
have a video here,
because the cool thing
is to see this in action
because the animations
are really slick.
So this is typically the entry
point for your big screen app,
if you have a media app.
And this is called
the browse fragment.
On the left, we have
a list of categories,
and you can think of
these like movies.
They might be action
movies, comedies, dramas.
And on the right,
we've got a list
of content-- rows
of content-- that
belong in those categories.
Another really common fragment
is the details fragment.
After you select a movie, I'd
like to view details of it.
And the cool thing is the
details fragment also comes
with these little actions.
The great thing about
these is they're all super
easy to navigate with a D-pad.
It just takes one or
two clicks and you just
sail right through it.
And then, of course,
when you've found content
that you want to watch,
you can play it back
with the playback overview
fragment, or overlay fragment,
I believe.
So these are all
totally prebuilt.
So working with Leanback, if you
just want-- and first of all,
they're totally customizable.
So the way they look now--
this is just straight out
of the sample app-- if
you open up Android Studio
and pull the
Leanback sample, this
is straight out of the sample.
They're totally customizable
in terms of colors and branding
and all of that.
You can also pull
pieces out of them
and roll your own
fragments from scratch.
And if you're building
for Android TV
these are also 100% optional.
So Leanback makes it super easy
to build a really great UI.
But you're totally not
required to use it,
and you can do your
own thing, if you like.
So here are the main
steps to using Leanback.
So here is an empty
browse fragment.
So when we updated our
manifest in the first step,
we declared an activity
to run on the TV.
If in that activity we
just specify a layout that
points to-- let's say we
extend the browse fragment,
we point that in our
layout, we can bring it up.
And when we bring it
up, it's totally empty.
So our job really
is-- let's say we
have a mobile app with a
bunch of videos-- our job is
to populate this with content.
So here's how it
looks under the hood.
So a layout that you don't
see because it's empty
is-- basically it's
a list of rows.
Each row has the columns for,
say, action movies, comedies,
dramedies.
Heh, dramedies?
Dramas.
These actually really are--
they sort of stick to a row.
So this whole thing, category
2 in the row is a row,
and category 1 in
the row is a row.
But Leanback-- just
this browse fragment--
has a list of these
rows, and our goal
is to map our content
onto the fragment.
And to do that, we
use a design pattern.
If you all are familiar
with model-controller-view
or model-view-controller,
this is model-view-presenter,
and it's a variant of it.
So the model is
your standard model.
These are objects
from your database.
Say these are movies.
When you're moving to Leanback,
if you have an existing model,
you don't need to make
any changes to it at all.
So no changes to
your data structure.
Views are standard Android
views, image views,
and text views.
So there's nothing new there.
And we have one new concept,
which is a presenter,
and a presenter's job is to
map from an object to a view.
So if I have a movie
in my database,
I would use a presenter
to create a view for it,
and then populate that view
with the different fields
from the movie.
By using different
presenters, you
can display the same object from
your model in different ways.
So this is the same movie.
Here's how it might look as a
card on the browse fragment,
and here's how it might look
on the details fragment.
Same movie, it's just
a different presenter,
putting different fields
in different places.
There's really two key
methods that you care about
in a presenter.
The first is onCreateViewHolder,
which creates a view.
Here we're looking at
a card presenter, which
creates an image card
view, which is just
composed of two standard Android
views, a text view and an image
view.
The second method that we care
about is onBindViewHolder,
and that takes an
object from the database
and just populates the
different fields on the view.
In computer science, it's all
about abstraction, abstraction,
abstraction.
And so I'm introducing some
abstract concepts really quick
just because, once
we have these,
we can wire them together
to quickly populate a UI.
So trust me and you'll see
where I'm going in a second.
The fragments
introduce a concept
called an ArrayObjectAdapter.
And that's a fancy word.
It's just an object and
it contains a presenter,
and a bunch of data.
And behind the
scenes, the fragment
will use the presenter to lay
out the data appropriately.
So this is one of the list
rows from the browse fragment,
and the idea is that it
has a card presenter So
to populate this
with our content,
all we really need to do is
add our movies to the object
adapter, give the object
adapter to our presenter,
and then the adapter in the
fragment behind the scenes
will take care of laying it out.
So using Leanback,
really you need
to write or use an
existing presenter,
and then just give it
the data from your model.
And the pattern is
the same when we
want to populate the rows
on the browse fragment.
We have a different
object adapter.
Instead of using a card
presenter, this time
we're using a list
row presenter.
And a list row presenter
is built into Leanback
and it understands
how to lay out
a whole row on the
browse fragment.
Right?
Here's a screenshot of some code
that you don't need to read.
The best way to learn
to use Leanback--
so this is a screenshot directly
out of the Leanback sample
included with Android Studio.
All of the code you
see here is used
to populate the browse fragment
with movies from a database.
So just this code--
this is really
the core code that will
go from your database
to a fully populated and
live browse fragment.
And the best way to learn it
is, I would go into this--
basically go into this
method of Leanback sample
and honestly just start
commenting out pieces.
I would start by
commenting out all the code
and slowly putting it
back in, and you'll just
see the UI populate
really rapidly.
So it's a surprisingly
small amount
of code for a surprising
amount of functionality,
and that's why I like
Leanback so much.
There's other prebuilt fragments
that you can use as well.
So this is the
guided step fragment.
It's great for providing
configuration options.
Works really great with a D-pad.
So basically we covered,
update your manifest.
That's mostly handling
hardware, adding new activity.
It's updating your UI.
That's mostly using
prebuilt fragments
and populating
them with content.
And then the last step
is really integrating
with recommendations and search.
One thing to keep in mind
about recommendations
is that a lot of apps
might be publishing Rex
to the home screen.
So one question is, how
should these be laid out?
The answer is,
behind the scenes,
Android TV uses a
recommendation engine,
and it tries to
prioritize recommendations
that are useful.
So it learns that
over time based
on what your users click on.
So you want to
avoid doing things--
like of course-- you want to
avoid things like spamming it.
And you want to really think
about-- A great example
of like a really solid
recommendation is,
imagine a user is
watching a TV show,
and they've watched like the
first three episodes of, maybe,
"Breaking Bad," a really
awesome recommendation
would be the next episode.
And then, when they click on
that, what you don't want to do
is take them into your app,
into some sort of window
describing the show.
You want to take them
directly into the video.
So the idea is that
a good recommendation
should go directly
from the home screen
into the content the
user wants to watch.
When you integrate with
search, Leanback also
includes a prebuilt
search fragment.
Which, again, you can customize.
So you don't need to
build a search UI,
you don't need to worry
about voice recognition.
All you have to do is
tie a content provider,
which basically describes what's
available in your database,
into the search fragment.
Then really quickly--
that's it for development--
and then really quick, I've got
just three slides on design.
And this is really up to you.
I think folks are
still figuring out
what's the optimal way to build
an app for the living room.
And we're still learning that.
I am an engineer,
not a designer.
But the designers at Google have
come up with three principles.
The first one is to
develop casual apps.
The idea is that--
as we've heard
before-- TV is super social.
Your users are in
the living room.
They're trying to relax after
work, and they're hanging out.
They might be watching
a movie, playing a game,
but they're definitely,
definitely not doing work.
The second design
principle the designers,
who are much smarter than me
in this area, came up with
is simple.
Voice recognition on Android
TV works really, really well.
It's powered by the same
software that powers it
on your phone, but if
you think about-- when
I'm trying to use my
phone on the street,
there's a tremendous amount--
this is a machine learning
problem-- there's a tremendous
amount of background noise,
right?
So voice recognition on the
street is really challenging.
In the living room,
it's often much quieter,
which means the accuracy
of the voice recognition
is often higher.
So voice search
is super powerful.
There's two ways to
input data on Android TV.
One is text entry.
Really don't want to
do that, unless it's
something like a password.
If it's anything
more than a password,
I would really look towards
voice, especially for search.
And then the last
design principle
is that we think that
the UI's that you
develop should be cinematic.
And by cinematic,
what that really means
is it should fade away.
So, ideally, the thing the user
cares about is the content.
If that's a movie
or if it's audio,
content should take up the
majority, or the entirety,
of the screen, and the
UI should just disappear.
Another thing that
I think is important
is low learning curve.
If you have a TV app, it should
be intuitive and simple to use,
right?
All right, so to
learn this stuff,
by far your best resource,
as always, is the docs.
I would focus on getting
the Leanback Library up
and running.
If you like learning
in video form,
we've also got a Udacity class.
The Udacity class
is really targeted--
if you're brand
new to Android TV,
the Udacity class is
taught at that level,
and it's a great way to go from
zero to a working Android TV
app.
And if you like
learning through code,
I would check out
the Leanback sample
on github, which you can also
pull through Android Studio.
And I think with these things,
these three things together,
it's pretty easy to
learn how to do this.
So, yeah, thanks very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]